every day
where we ask a question to ourselves
shall i do that or
i mean we we do that
so
where can we take aikido in daily life
coach heytel
he was um
i think it was 10th then in there but i
sense he said he was the only person
that he'd ever trained who he felt could
surpass
surpass him
such a sense he said
that's why i only teach basics he said i
just if you want to know about this that
this stuff
please go and search out another person
because he said
i can only show you the basics because i
didn't understand even though i was with
osensee 24 7 my wife cared for his wife
i cared for scentsy
but i didn't understand him to me
it was all
we used the word gobbledygook you know
words that he just didn't understand
some religions call it talking with
speaking in tongues
so
another person
from like another planet can understand
this person but the majority of people
can't
so
so in daily life
you'll be asking these questions to
yourself but you're not listening for
the answer usually years ago
i don't know whether i should do that or
not
we're really truthfully you already know
the answer
do you know i don't know how to do that
or not but
it's as if you're sort of like
should i do it
you you know the answer you just don't
want to go
god do i need a haircut you know you're
not looking in the mirror and listening
to the answer
so we can get most answers out of
our questions
this is all i'm doing
i've been plugged into danny ever since
he's been sitting there
i know his shape his pyramid i know
everything about him now because
i've been
focused on him
so
so he will cut down so we'll do it
slowly
and your hand will go on top
now it looks like i'm on top
he'll think that the pressure is coming
down
but i'm fooling him really whether where
the pressure is
so you got it okay
is the same as when i had the ken
is there
it's there
when your finger
bounced a little bit
because you was trying to get it so
light that it actually bounced
if i allow that bounce to be magnified
so
it's the down but if i
lose a little bit of that up now
i'm struggling so i can't now get him
over here you see
so what i have to do is so we all know
already that that's the direction
but
the same as you ask a question in the
daytime but don't listen to the answer
when you already know the answer this is
the same thing
he knows that it's going to be this way
i know it's going to be this way but
what happens is
we actually
wow about getting it wrong
where really it was always
there
so i mustn't let my my mind waver
over
i'm trying to give him this
but i know
that i mustn't make a gap
in my mind
or else that won't come so i'm going to
make a gap in my mind i'm going to go
pushing down i'm going to take my mind
off it and look at some i'm going to
look at the fan in there now i'm going
to try and pull him look
go on can't get him
it's because i broke the connection
if i keep the connection
you'll see it as physical
and i'll just go
so the lighter i can get it
so that you try
slowly first
and then
just see see what materializes
but they're all connected so you're not
you don't have to do anything special or
be or change your line of thinking all
you have to know is if you ask a
question
should i buy this
phone
you'll know the answer but if you have a
gap and don't
take the answer that you already know
it will either be yes or no if you don't
take that answer that's the gap
so in a martial arts sense
you will be defeated
at height at higher levels because
they will regain
the mass okay